le château frontenac et l'hôtel le plus
photographié du monde
la rue du petit-champlain est reconnue
comme étant la rue la plus remarquable
du canada mais leur charme ne perd plus
de la même façon privée des touristes
étrangers
les visiteurs se font rares dans le
vieux québec la capitale a enregistré
une baisse d'achalandage de plus de 60 %
en 2020 cet incident de la magic
on commence à avoir des cinq qui sont
beaucoup plus encourageant pour cet été
mais il faut travailler fort pour bien
cet été pour aider l'industrie
sans ces festivals et son effervescence
la capitale à peine à séduire le marché
québécois
c'est sûr que le marché est plus limité
donc est-ce qu'on va retourner aux
normales cette année la réponse sinon
mais on va nettement supérieur à qu'est
ce qu'on a vécu l'année passée l'état ne
suffira pas à combler le manque à gagner
les touristes québécois ne laisse pas
les mêmes presse dans l'économie lors de
leur séjour les touristes étrangers
dépensent deux fois plus et certaines
clientèles ne peuvent tout simplement
pas être au rendez vous pour une
deuxième année d'affilée
normalement en ce beau il s'est plaint
parce que c'est la grosse saison des
congrès ça commence habituellement vers
la mi mars jusqu'à la fin juin en tout 2
110 événement qui devait avoir lieu au
centre des congrès de québec ont été
annulés ce qui représente 130 millions
de dollars 2 - en retombées économiques
pour les hôteliers et les restaurants
dans cette industrie
la reprise sera lente on ne prévoit pas
de retour à la normale avant 2024
la compétition va être vivre mais on est
quand même au moins une vingtaine de
centre des congrès du type de celui ci à
travers le canada qui sont toutes à la
recherche de même clientèle parce que le
nombre d'associations s'est pas
multiplié pendant la pandémie si y'a de
quoi il y en a moins
donc tout le monde on travaille sur le
même marché et puis les quais du port de
québec seront à nouveau désert
les croisières sont interdits au canada
jusqu'en février 2022
rocheteau actuellement lorsqu'on appelle
le terminal tron
tonnes 2021 on aurait dû recevoir les
premiers passagers mais le parquet
contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur faute
de passagers
le nouveau terminal de croisières a été
transformée en centre de vaccination
l'absence de croisiéristes prive
l'industrie touristique de 711 millions
de dollars et ce ne sera pas simple de
ramener des bateaux à qui les temps sont
durs pour les compagnies de croisières
qui pour garder la tête hors de l'eau
plusieurs ont dû se départir de navires
par là même le cas vendu plusieurs
bateaux dont ceux qui venaient sur le
cndd verrez plus levine dames le maasdam
qu'on est habitué de voir à québec de 20
fois par année
nous ce qu'on voit 2012 sans redémarrer
gratuits en europe au niveau qu'on avait
en 2019 à 23,4 même cinq heures donc ça
redevienne ce que c'était en 2009 ça va
prendre plus de temps
dans ce contexte plusieurs
établissements touristiques remettent
leur survie entre les mains des
québécois en avril dernier l'association
hôtelière de québec a sondé ses membres
20 % d'entre eux se disaient en mesure
de tenir le coup pendant moins de six
mois la moitié - dana sur ce que le
message vraiment sortait supporter
dépenser parce que si on a la moitié des
joueurs
à québec des platanes futur et si
valérie gamache radio canada québec